[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: OK, thank you
everyone for coming.
Today at Google, we're delighted
to have Mr. Scott Hartley.
Mr. Hartley is a venture
capitalist and an author.
He was a partner at
Morh Davidow Ventures,
a very highly regarded
venture capital firm based out
of Sand Hill Road.
Then prior to that, he was a
presidential innovation fellow
at the White House.
He has also worked
at Google, Facebook,
and he was a fellow at
the Harvard Berkman Center
for Internet and Society.
He took his BA from Stanford
and his MBA from Columbia.
And he is a term member on the
Council of Foreign Relations.
He is here today to discuss
his new book, "The Fuzzy
and the Techie, Why Liberal Arts
Will Rule the Digital World."
And joining him on stage is
Google's on own Albert Chen.
Please join me in welcoming
Mr. Scott Hartley.
[APPLAUSE]
ALBERT CHEN: So welcomes, Scott.
Or I should say, welcome back.
So let's start with the
inspiration behind the book,
and what a fuzzy is and
what a techie is as well.
SCOTT HARTLEY:
Well, first of all,
it's really a
pleasure and an honor
to be back on Google
campus about 10 years
or so after leaving.
Albert and I go way back,
12-plus years, here at Google.
So it's really fun to be back
and to join all of you guys.
So the impetus for writing
the book, "The Fuzzy
and the Techie" was really
based on my experience, both
in my own personal journey,
being a political science
major, being someone who
studied political theory,
definitely identifying as a
fuzzy, yet coming out of school
and joining Google and having
all my friends say well,
what are you doing at Google?
How are you working in tech?
And I think this has become
something that people
understand more today.
But 10, 12 years ago, I felt
like all my friends coming out
of university, if they didn't
study electronic engineering
or computer science,
they didn't understand
that there were
other people in tech
and it wasn't just this
monolith of techies.
And so based on my own personal
journey of being this--
presumed to be this
black sheep when I
didn't feel like a black sheep.
I felt like there were so
many people in this world that
were participating from all
different walks of life,
all different sides of
academic background--
I wanted to tell that story that
was a myth busting of the tech
monolith that we presume
to be Silicon Valley.
And the second reason
was because on Sand Hill,
where I was I in BC, so
many of the companies that
were pitching, so many of the
companies that were starting
were founded by people
that were coming from all
these different backgrounds.
And I thought the narrative in
Silicon Valley, the narrative
that we hear about
in the media, has
been if you don't have a STEM
degree, you're worthless.
If you didn't drop
out of middle school
to study computer
science, there's
no hope for you in the future.
And the actual observation I
had, the empirical observation
sitting on Sand Hill
and meeting with all
these different
entrepreneurs and all
these different companies
was so many of the good ideas
were coming from
people that came out
of different walks of life,
different backgrounds,
different disciplines,
different passions.
And the observation was
that the code in some ways
had been commoditized,
and the ability
to get things built, we were
getting farther and farther
away, more and more
abstractions away
from having to write
really esoteric syntax
or really learning the details
and nuance of certain coding
languages.
We were getting these bigger
and bigger building blocks.
And so the code in some
ways had been commoditized.
And really, the
comparative advantage
of these really good companies
was somebody with passion,
somebody with the
domain expertise,
somebody with some sort of
other disciplinary knowledge
to which they were
playing the code.
And so that was impetus
for writing the book
was myth-bust this
narrative, that so many
of the interesting
companies that we
were meeting with
and funding and that
are profiled in the book were
founded by people coming out
of backgrounds in
philosophy, backgrounds
in sociology, backgrounds
in political science,
coming out of fashion or media
or finance or telecom, all
these different backgrounds.
And so the terms,
fuzzy and techie,
is anyone in the room
familiar with these terms?
No?
So they date back to the
1960s, 1970s from Stanford,
where there was this
lighthearted association where
people would ask a question--
and they still do--
are you more of a Fuzzy
are you more of a techie?
Are you taking
more fuzzy classes
this quarter, more
techie classes?
And obviously, techie being
computer science, engineering
disciplines, fuzzy being
more arts, humanities,
and social sciences.
But really, the book
is not about one
versus the other,
fuzzy versus techie.
It's about this
intertwining of the two,
because I think you look
under the hood of any
of these disciplines, any
of these methodologies,
and if you're studying
social science,
you're often forced to grapple
with statistical software
or deal with independent
and dependent variables.
If you're studying
international relations,
you're dealing with game theory.
And if you're studying
mechanical engineering,
on the flip side, you're
learning design thinking.
You're using methodologies
of sociology and anthropology
to do user experience research.
So I think it's
not that we can say
one group is uniformly techie
and one group is uniformly
fuzzy.
It's much more about how
we blend these two sides
and how so many of the
innovations that I think
make Google successful and
make so many great startups
in Silicon Valley
successful is actually
this blending of the two, rather
than this narrative of tech
is going to solve all,
big data, algorithms, AI,
this uniformly
techie explanation
is going to solve all.
ALBERT CHEN: Thank you.
Yeah, yeah, absolutely.
So let's start with
one of his themes
and closer to home for Google.
In the book, you talk
a lot about big data
and that need for human
input to inform things,
including a company
called Kaggle,
which is now a part of Google.
Can you talk a little
bit more about that?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah, so Kaggle--
I don't know if any of you
guys are familiar with Kaggle.
It was founded by an
Australian economist.
It's basically a
platform where you
can put big data
to work and then
crowdsource different
explanations,
different observations
on the data.
And so companies can post
public or proprietary data
sets, behind an NDA, behind
a non-disclosure agreement,
and really get this diverse set
of people looking at the data,
trying to find whatever
answer you're seeking.
And so it's a competition
platform, which
was acquired, I
believe, in March,
It's now part of Google Cloud.
But Anthony Goldbloom, he
really had this observation
while he was working
for "The Economist"
actually that there is all this
really fascinating data that
was locked up, siloed
within companies.
And he said, why
can't we crowdsource?
Why can't we bring the
wealth of global expertise
against this data?
And there are these
really fascinating--
if you look at the
case studies of Kaggle,
where for example, The
Royal Astronomical Society
and NASA and the
European Space Agency
were trying to quantify
dark matter in the universe.
And they had been working
on this for a decade.
And they released this dataset.
And they found-- it was
a glaciologist, actually,
from the UK, who was using
algorithms that were looking
at measuring the edge of a
glacier from space imagery,
that he was able
to quantify, he was
able to use some of those
tactics, kind of orthogonally,
from this completely
different domain
in this explanation of trying
to quantify dark matter.
And he got closer to
the approximations
that NASA and these
cosmologists had
been working on for a
decade in a matter of weeks.
And I think it's a
really incredible example
of putting other human expertise
in the mix with big data.
Another example in
the book is Palantir,
which is down the street in Palo
Alto and now around the world.
And Palantir is a
big data company
that we forget is run by
a guy named Alex Karp, who
has a PhD in neoclassical
social theory, and was also
co-founded by Peter
Thiel, who has
a degree in philosophy and law.
So it's a big data company.
But one of the guys who's
a director at Palantir,
he has a TED Talk, this
guy named Shyam Sankar.
And he talks about how there's
no terrorist find button.
So for anyone familiar
with Palantir,
it's a big data science company.
But there are these huge human
components behind the scenes.
When you think or you
collect the data from bunch
of three-letter agencies-- from
FBI and from different groups--
and you think, well,
if we just going
to plug all this data
together, suddenly, big data
is going to have
all these answers,
we forget that Voltaire said,
judge a man by his questions,
not by his answers.
And I think we still require
smart questioners sitting
in front of this newly surfaced
data in interesting new ways.
But in the case of
Palantir, it really
requires the battlefield
commander, the intelligence
officer, the people that are
transcribing data and codifying
it in certain ways,
putting it into the system
in certain ways,
picking the taxonomy
of how they look at the data.
So we forget that
behind these buzz words
that from a VC
standpoint, we love
to see them on slide
decks, but at some point,
you have to take a
step back and say,
well, is every company that
we see a big data company?
Is every company we see
an artificial intelligence
company?
Not really.
It's really about this blending
of human and data, human
and machine.
ALBERT CHEN: OK, OK, awesome.
One of the other
things you touched on
is automation and the
concept of algorithms.
And those are some examples.
The example you use in the book
is Stitch Fix, which is what--
I think it's cool.
How does that apply to fashion?
And why is that a great example?
SCOTT HARTLEY:
Yeah, well, I think
you're much more fashionable
up here than I am.
But Stitch Fix, I don't know.
Is anyone familiar
with Stitch Fix?
Yeah, a few hands
in the audience.
They just rolled out the
men's clothing recently.
But it's been in the
market for women's clothing
for a few years.
But Stitch Fix is a
fascinating example
because, really, it's sort
of Netflix for fashion.
So what they've done is they've
taken articles of clothing.
They've employed
different people
from fashion backgrounds,
from style backgrounds, where
they are able to classify
the clothing according
to 100 to 150 characteristics.
So whether it's the width of the
lapel or the style of button,
all these different
characteristics,
the start identifying
what clothing,
you know where it fits.
And then through connecting
like Pinterest APIs,
through queries and polling
of your style habits,
they're able to start matching
what your preferences might
be for a certain type of
fashion with the characteristics
inherent in certain clothing
items that you pick.
And over time,
they're developing
this Netflix-like algorithm to
better service clothing to you
in a really automated,
streamlined way.
But what's fascinating
about Stitch Fix is--
I mean, one, it was founded
by Katrina Lake, who
is an economics major,
not deeply technical.
She had a vision though.
And she had this passion to
want to solve this problem.
She was working in
retail consulting,
didn't have any time
to shop for herself,
didn't have the time
to do it on her own.
And she said, why is it
that I can sit down and have
all of my content served
to me via Netflix,
but I can't have
certain e-commerce items
served me in the
time and the fashion
that I want to receive them?
And so she realized that
this was a heavy logistics
operation.
It was going to
require a lot of SKUs
and a lot of clothing
items moving around.
So she said, well,
who's good at logistics?
She said, well, Walmart's
good at logistics.
Why don't I go try to
hire the CEO of Walmart?
And so she went and found
the CEO of walmart.com.
Got him to quit his job.
Worked for her when she
was still in the dorm room.
And that kind of grit,
that kind of passion
to be able to convince
and tell the story
is so much more important in
some ways than the ability
to actually code the product.
Right?
It was that ability to
tell the story, ability
to tell the narrative to
convince somebody to leave
a job as CEO of walmart.com.
And she not only did that,
but then she said, well,
if this is Netflix,
we need somebody who's
really good at data science.
So why not go get the guy who
built Netflix's algorithms?
His name is Eric Colson.
So she went and
approached Eric and was
able to convince Eric to leave
his job as this chief data
scientist at Netflix, who had
built the whole team to build
the algorithms that run how
Netflix provides its movies.
And so through this
combination, she
was able to build this
killer team around her.
But the most interesting thing,
I think, into your question
is Eric is somebody that,
even though he's a data
scientist, even though he's
a huge believer in the tech
behind the scenes, he's also
a huge believer in the human.
And so he basically
talks about how
he has his M
algorithm for machine,
and he has his H
algorithm for his humans.
And he's got about 70 or 80
data scientists on his team.
But they've got about 4,000
stylists that do all the
and delivery of the product.
So I think when we take a
step back from this assumption
in the 140-character
Twitter universe of reading
headlines and seeing
AI and automation
are taking everything
over, and we
forget that behind
the 60 or 80 data
scientists are 4,000
stylists really looking
at the nuance of geography
and your own fashion sense.
The machine algorithm is
serving them a subset of items
that they think will be
pretty relevant to you,
but then the last
mile delivery is all
based on who you are,
what you say you like,
your personality and
actual interactions.
There's really this last
mile human delivery.
And one of the most fascinating
things about that is it's
not treating the
human as problematic,
but it's using machine
learning to try
to use the human as a
classification problem.
So if I have my own biases in
how I serve clothing to you
that you either accept
or don't accept,
we can use the machine
learning to actually mitigate
my own biases, and how
if I'm based in Brooklyn,
or I'm based in Des
Moines, I might have
a different sense of
what's fashion forward,
or what's hipster, or what's
one of these classifications.
So the machine
learning can actually
help me perform better
as a human stylist.
So I think it's a really
fascinating example
of not primacy of--
it's not the Luddite
no technology,
and it's not the primacy
of techie-only solutions,
but it's really about
blending these two sides.
So Stitch Fix is
something that I think
is a great example of that.
ALBERT CHEN: OK, OK.
I want to dive
into one of things
you mentioned, so
about automation,
about tasks moving
away from human.
So depending on what you read,
anywhere between like 1/3 up
to close to 50% of American
jobs, quote unquote,
are at risk due to
automation and machines.
What do you think about that?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah,
so I mean, back
to the question about the
reason for writing the book.
I really felt like the
narrative and the pendulum of--
Martin Ford's "Rise of the
Robots" was a great book.
I don't know if
anyone has read that.
But this sort of message of
fear and the narrative of fear.
And I thought the
pendulum has got
to come back toward
hope because I
don't agree with 50% of all
jobs are disappearing tomorrow.
And that quote, it really
refers to this study.
In 2014, Oxford came
out with a study
where they said 47% of US jobs
are at high risk of machine
automation.
It didn't really define
on what timeline.
Technological ability
is not the same thing
as immediately substituting
for jobs tomorrow.
Obviously, there's
an economic question.
There's a labor question.
There's the flexibility
of labor question.
There's all these other
components to that.
So more recently, in January,
McKinsey Global Institute
came out with a study
that hit pause and said,
let's take a step back.
Let's look at this 47% number,
and let's think about this.
And so they looked at
800 different occupations
across the US.
And they broke up
those occupations
into the tasks that make up
those jobs, because like we all
know, any job, you've got
100 different tasks that you
do on a daily basis.
And some of those things
are best practices.
Some of the things
are really rote.
They're repeatable.
You've got maybe your
best practices list
on your desk on the wall for how
to go through a process Those
are things that, because
you've done them so many times
before, they can be scripted.
They can be programmmed.
They can be machine
automatable pretty fast.
Right?
So I think it behooves all of
us to look within our own jobs
and say, well, what are
the things that I'm doing
over and over and over again?
What are things that
are best practices?
Those are things
we could probably
make more efficient
through the use of machine
learning through the use
of different technology.
But then there's all these other
tasks that are highly variable.
David Autor, who's
an economist at MIT,
talks about routine
and non-routine tasks.
And so routine tasks
can be both manual,
or they can be cognitive.
Routine tasks that
are manual are
things that robots can maybe
do because they're physical.
Routine cognitive tasks are
things that machine learning
can proudly start doing.
But non-routine things,
whether they're cognitive,
like things you do at
work that are highly
variable, interfacing
with other humans,
collaborating with
teams, those are
things that are not going
to go away anytime soon.
And then on the
manual side of things,
non-routine manual
would be, for example,
like livestock farming.
Things that have
a high variability
are things that maybe machines--
maybe robots can get some
way into hydroponic farming
indoors, because it's
highly repeatable.
But for things like livestock
farming or construction
outdoors, these are things that
are still pretty non-routine,
things that are still generally
going to be done by humans.
And so I really like
the McKinsey study
because it really takes this
granularity and looks at that.
And overall, what they found
was that they thought 5% of jobs
had 100% of tasks
that could eventually,
over some period of time, be
substituted with machines.
And that's still a
huge number of jobs
that, I think, beg real social
and political questions and all
that.
But for 60% of jobs, they said
30% of the tasks in those jobs
are things that could be
substituted over time.
So much more than just this
all-or-nothing robots are
taking over the world, AI
is taking over the world,
I think it's going to look
much more like this gradual
progression of--
In our cars, we've had manual
to automatic transmissions.
We've got park assists.
We've got antilock
brakes, we've got
all this sort of fly-by-wire
in our cars and our planes.
I think thinking about this
more like desktop assists
and driver assists in
the sense that we'll
have things that
say, hey, you're
gonna send this email out.
You're gonna post this
thing to social media.
You're going to do whatever.
Based on the data
that we have, we
would suggest you
wait 30 minutes.
Would you like to
delay that post?
These minor nudges, I
think, are much more
where this is going to impact
us on a day-to-day basis
in the near term.
OK
ALBERT CHEN: OK, I love that's.
So I shouldn't be worried yet.
I'm kidding.
SCOTT HARTLEY: I think
the pendulum is swinging
a little bit back
toward hope because I
think these tools really have--
flipping the letters
around, there's
a lot of talk about
artificial intelligence.
But I think when you
go back to the debates
of the 1950s between Marvin
Minsky JCR Licklider, who
I talk about the book a bit--
there was this debate about
artificial intelligence
and intelligence augmentation
and thinking about,
if you flip the
letters around, how do
we make humans more productive?
How do we make humans better?
I think the Stitch Fix example
is a really interesting case
for that, because a stylist has
all these fallabilities, all
these biases that are implicit.
But can we use machine
learning, can we
use these things to actually
help mitigate those biases
and make that person
more productive?
And that's the intelligence
augmentation, rather than
just the pure AI.
ALBERT CHEN: One of the themes
that I love that you touch on,
the attention economy
and that concept.
Can you explain
that a little bit?
And then there's
another former Googler
who's written a lot about
this, Tristan Harris,
that ethics in design
and how we have
to think about the menu of
choices in product design.
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yes, so
Tristan Harris, he's
a former Googler as well.
He was here.
He sold his company--
it's called Apture--
to Google back in 2011 or so.
He became a product manager,
and then quickly fashioned
himself the in-house product
philosopher, or one of many,
and really took
this observation,
who was in the room as we're
making these product decisions.
I think in the
past, we've thought
a lot about who
wields massive scale
or impact of their decisions.
And we're quick to
point fingers at the MBA
at the helm of an
investment bank,
or at the helm of an
Enron, or a company that's
done something wrong.
On we forget that today,
in the digital economy,
we have this same
moral obligation
to think about how we're
multiplying out effects
when we make product
decisions that are
affecting billions of people.
And so Tristan was
asking these questions,
shining a light on what's the
diversity of our teams, who's
in the room making
product decisions,
how are we thinking about
not just engagement metrics,
not just monetizing via
ad revenue, not just
the key performance
indicators that our venture
capitalists or our
public shareholders
want to think about.
But if we flip this around
we think about as consumers,
as humans, 100
million-plus smartphones,
60 to 80 interruptions
per day, you
start looking at the actual
externalities of this,
from a time perspective, from
an interruption with their kids
perspective, from a
lifestyle perspective,
and it begs a whole
new set of questions.
And so Tristan basically
doesn't have these as answers,
but he's posing these questions.
And he left Google recently
to start a movement called
the Time Well Spent movement,
which looks at this attention
economy and how we think
about these choices
that we're making, how
we develop the menus,
he calls them,
within our products.
Because we're all
moving around our world.
If we want to get together to
grab a drink after this event,
we'll, chances
are, turn to Yelp,
or we'll turn to OpenTable.
We'll turn to a
product where we're
interfacing with the
technology layer that
has implicit choices of how it
surfaces information to us, how
it presumes what we want because
of our geography or our age
or various things
that those product
managers, those engineers,
have had determined for us.
And so these sorts of questions
that Tristan poses, I think,
are really important
as we build our team
to think about these things.
And he gets into some of
the sort of philosophy
in thinking about
how Steve Jobs made
this comment that the
personal computer should
be a bicycle for the mind.
And Tristan says, wait a minute.
Unfortunately, the smartphone
in our pocket has in some ways
become a slot machine.
It's become the
one finger bandit
that steals away our
time the same way
that a one lever bandit
from a slot machine
takes our money
one coin at a time.
It's one perspective.
But how do we think about this?
Should there be LEED certified,
like for a green building?
Should there be an FDA?
Should there be some
sort of thinking
about how we as a
society construct
some sort of check
and balance on how
we want our own personal time
to be manipulated in some ways.
And really, he doesn't
have a yes or no answer
for any of these
things, but says,
well, we retain agency
as personal individuals.
We still do that when
we walk into Starbucks.
But we have calorie menus.
We know how many calories
in our frappucino
versus a black coffee.
We can still choose
whatever we want to choose.
But should there be
those sorts of things
baked into our
technology that allow us,
as consumers, as users, as
humans, as individuals, to be
making the choices
that we actually want
to make with our technology?
ALBERT CHEN: OK, awesome.
Let's take a step back towards
the overall theme of the book.
So you mentioned--
and I think some of us
feel in the room too, folks who,
for me, like political science
and history background, looking
at the industry that I'm in,
not having a STEM degree,
that maybe I don't know
how long my career could go.
So can you talk a bit more
about your perspective on this
and why these skills
continue to matter?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah,
so back to the code--
I think it's a multipart
question where really,
in some ways, the
chunks of technology
have become larger and
larger building blocks.
And there was a great
article in "TechCrunch"
a few years ago about the end
of the full stack developer
and the rise of the
full stack integrator.
And I love that
quote because I think
it speaks so much to being
able to know where the building
blocks are.
TensorFlow is an
incredible tool.
You no longer need to
know all the nuances
to be able to get a
product off the ground,
or to be able to create an MVP,
a minimum viable product, sir
create applicable prototype.
So I think more
and more it's about
what are you passionate about?
What the context to which
you would apply the code?
The book is not anti-STEM.
System It's not anti
any of these things.
I think you've got to have
enough technical literacy,
enough break the ice,
be technical enough
to be dangerous, which
anyone at Google, I think,
has already crossed that line.
But I think it's about
taking these methodologies,
taking these passions,
and really unlocking
these new industries.
Marc Andreesson
talks a lot about how
software is eating the world.
But on the flip side,
I think software
is feeding the
world in the sense
that now, if you're
coming from a background
like political science,
like the two of us--
there's a guy I feature in
the book named Zac Bookman.
And he founded this amazing
company called OpenGov.
And OpenGov was based on
his own personal passion
for transparency in
government, which
was rooted in studying political
science, going to law school.
He worked at the Ninth
Circuit in San Francisco
on issues around transparency.
He went to Mexico looking
at transparency issues
on a Fulbright.
He went to Afghanistan
with General HR McMaster
to work on transparency
issues in Afghanistan.
And rather than the
proverbial garage,
he was living in a container,
literally a shipping container,
in Kabul.
And he had this idea
of, wait a minute.
We're holding the Afghans to
this incredibly high standard
of transparency.
Do even have this
at home in America?
And so he came back,
started talking
to City Hall in Palo Alto.
He thought, this was the
heart of Silicon Valley.
They must have their
ducks in a row.
They must have all their
data visible and digestible.
And on the contrary, it
was literally in boxes,
printed out Excel files.
And so they created,
effectively,
the mint.com of
municipal finance data,
where you can look and see all
of the public expenditures,
public revenues, for
1,000-plus cities.
And I think that
kind of company,
sitting on Sand Hill Road,
sitting in a venture capital
seat, is so interesting
because it's
taking technology and applying
it meaningfully to this problem
that Zac really understood
and really had a passion for.
And he partnered
with Joe Lonsdale,
actually, who co-founded
Palantir, co-founded a couple
other companies, as a techie.
But it was really about this
blending of the two sides.
And really, the
comparative advantage
of what OpenGov off the
ground was Zac's passion
for transparency, not the
ability to create a platform
to visualize data.
And so I think there are
so many examples like that,
that really show the way of--
it's not just people in
management positions.
There are plenty
of those people,
like Susan Wojcicki
from YouTube, history
and literature major.
Or I mentioned Alex
Karp from Palantir,
know neoclassical social theory.
Or Steve Case from AOL
was a history major.
Emily White, who used to
run Instagram and Snapchat
was a studio art
and fine arts major.
So there's so many
different examples.
It's not just about cherry
picking those examples,
but thinking about the
underlying methodologies of--
Slack, Stewart
Butterfield, for example,
both in undergrad and then grad
school, studied philosophy.
And he really tributes product
design, product development
to this unlocking of
this pursuit of truth,
where you peel pack
the onion repeatedly
and you go through this
process of inquiry.
And I think that we understand
the A-to-A linearity
of study engineering,
become an engineer.
But we forget study
anthropology, study sociology,
user experience, study
philosophy, product management,
product design.
There's so many
different lines that I
think we can draw
from these skillsets
if you take a step back
and don't fall victim
to the narrative that these
degrees are worthless,
that these skills are worthless.
Because if anything, these
are the vital components
to how we humanize
technology, how we actually
take technology make it useful
for what it's meant for,
which is to improve our lives.
ALBERT CHEN: OK, so if we think
about the next generation--
and you knew I was going to ask
you this question, because I
love the concept of education.
There's a number of tech
billionaires investing
in schools, being somewhat
directive about curriculum
content, things like that.
And "The New York
Times" is currently
publishing a series of
articles about this.
What happens if we take it
too far in one direction?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah,
that's a great question,
and it's something that Steve
Jobs talked a number of years
back about how the next
big platform for innovation
was going to be education.
And I think you're
starting to see that.
Rick Levin, former
president of Yale,
left Yale to become
the CEO of Coursera.
That's not the path that
most academics would have
foreseen a few decades ago.
So I think there is
this understanding
that the scale and impact we
can have through technology
is massive, but
thinking about, how
do we engage with the
new tools, but not
lose some of the old ways.
And there are a bunch of
examples in "The New York
Times" article you mentioned,
like Marc Benioff has been
really engaged in this process.
Zuckerberg, through the
Chan Zuckerberg Initiative,
has invested in a group called
the Summit Public Schools,
which is based mostly
here in the Bay Area.
But what they've done is they've
engaged with technologies.
They use the iPad, for
example, to deliver lectures.
But they create this really
personalized experience
where the teacher actually
has become the coach.
So the teacher is
walking around the room,
almost like if you had in
soccer practice, doing a drill,
and the coach is walking
around, checking in on everybody
as they're performing.
But I think that way of
engaging with technology,
not shunning it--
I talk a little bit about
Waldorf Schools in the book
and taking a completely
hands-off approach to tech.
But in some ways, I
think that while that's
popular in Silicon Valley,
we're privileged in the sense
that we have tech all around
us, in our homes, other places.
So it's one thing to say, don't
deal with tech in the school
because we all work at Google,
we all work at Facebook,
we all work at these
fancy tech companies.
That's easy for us to say.
But I think across
America, where
people don't have that access
to technology in our schools,
how do we think about
engaging with the tools,
but doing it in a way that still
fosters collaboration, still
fosters communication,
still builds
a lot of these soft skills
that are so important?
So there's a really
interesting example
of a guy in India
who put computers out
in public in New Delhi,
in the slums in basically
this self-organizing
learning environment.
He called it a sole, S-O-L-E,
and gave us a great TED Talk
about this.
And it actually inspired the
movie "Slumdog Millionaire"
through this exposure.
And in these soles, he basically
unleashes technology and lets
kids do with it what they want.
And the results are
really astounding.
And so I think
what's interesting is
if you provide the tools and
provide a messy question, which
is something I talk
about in the book--
these messy questions are
things you can't really Google.
And they're fun because
we live in this world
where people say, well, all
the answers are already Google.
So what's the point?
Just give a kid an iPad.
They'll figure it out.
Actually, this example
of messy questions
is really fun because you ask
things that are unGoogleable,
like why aren't our ears square?
So it begs the question of,
well, how do acoustics work?
How did the ears develop?
It goes into all these
different areas of exploration.
And so you show this to
a class of third graders
and they immediately
start googling
all these different things,
watching YouTube videos,
learning about
acoustics, learning
about different human biology.
But then also, the second layer
is this collaboration that's
happening between them and
even this tertiary layer
of figuring out what
sources they trust,
what sources they don't trust.
In this Facebook
newsfeed world, how
are we thinking about
red feed and blue feed
and what sources we choose
to trust and all that?
And I think these
are things that
are really interesting
ways that you
can engage with the technology,
but then still teach
these underlying skills.
ALBERT CHEN: It's
been about a year
since you've written the book.
And things move at quite
a pace in the Valley,
and outside as well.
What companies are
doing this well?
And if you're not a
company that's doing well,
how do you think about that?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Well, I
think we've seen Uber
in the news a lot recently.
I'd say, from a cultural
standpoint, that's
one that I think they
probably could figure out
a way to do better.
I think Google--
I'm biased from having
spent so much time here
and loving the company.
But I think that Google, from
back to days as a product
specialist here
sitting on core teams,
where there really are a lot of
different people in the room.
There are different
perspectives.
There is a marketing
person, a lawyer.
I was the representative to
online sales or direct sales.
There are all these
different people
bringing this diversity
of perspectives.
And I think that
modular approach
to product development, I
found to be really effective.
I know that creating these
trusted environments where
you can brainstorm openly, IDO
does a good job at that, where
you don't judge on
the surface, you
provide an open sharing
platform for brainstorming.
I think that fosters the
trust and the ability
to unlock using social
skills and all this.
But it's a good question.
And I think it's
something that--
I think through blending
these two sides,
bringing together
fuzzy and techie--
again, it's not a monolith of
techie and a monolith of fuzzy,
but the two sides.
And then from
innovation standpoint,
I think there are
so many ways that we
can be unlocking the
problems that we have
all across the country
and all across the world,
and partnering with
technologists who really know
the new tools, that are
in search of applications
for the tools.
And so the Defense
Department has
created DIUx, which is down
the street at Moffett Field.
They've done a
great job, I think,
of taking some of the problems
that are really rooted in DC,
rooted in different parts of the
State Department, USA military,
and brought them out to
Silicon Valley and said,
here's what we're
struggling with.
Here the problems that we have.
Are there ways we can
engage with technology
to help fix these.
And Steve Blank, who's an
entrepreneurship professor
at Stanford and
Berkeley and at Columbia
sometimes while,
he's created a class,
it's called Hack for
Defense, and another one
called Hack for Diplomacy.
And it basically takes a
mixture of political scientists,
people from different
fuzzy backgrounds,
and engineering students
and pairs them on teams
and puts them against one
of these problems that's
sourced by a different agency.
I think they're a
really great example
of Fuzzy and techie, how we
can take this problem centric
approach, rather
than just building
technology in the abstract
and then looking for some way
to apply it.
AUDIENCE: I have a question
just in regards to the education
piece again.
I went to a college
that had a big core
curriculum where I took a
lot of liberal arts things.
I had to take an art
class and a music class.
And some of the benefit
I feel like you're
talking about with
the fuzzy comes
from having this
innate subject matter
expertise or this deep
knowledge of something
that you're curious about.
I was wondering, as you look
at education moving forward,
is there still a place for this
kind of general core curriculum
or base level of knowledge
you need to have?
Or do you really
think it comes down
to just letting somebody pursue
what they're interested in
and just going as deep as
possible in that direction?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah.
It's a great question.
Actually, yesterday, I sat
down with the Vice Provost
of Undergraduate
Education at Stanford.
And we were talking
about this metaphor.
He's talked to a bunch students
that treat their-- they
call them ballistic
students, where
they're good at getting
where they want to get.
And they're on this trajectory
of I'm trying to get to this--
you know, from
point A to point B.
And I don't want to see
anything in between.
I know how to execute along
that vector and I'm going.
And he said, rather than
treating your education
like a plane ticket,
where you get from here
to Frankfurt, what do you
do with the plane ticket?
You throw it in the trash can.
Now you're in Frankfurt.
How do you think about this in
terms of tugging on the mind
and getting a breadth of
exposure to different ideas?
And he had this notion of
education as the passport.
And it's a passport that's
infinitely renewable,
that you want to get stamps
from all over the world.
And you really want
to collect stamps
from things that
push your boundaries.
So if you spend a lot of time in
Europe, you want to go to Asia.
If you spend a lot of time in
Asia, you want to go to Africa.
How do you create this
metaphor and how do you
get students to think about
their education not as a plane
ticket to point B, which is
a job as a product manager
at a fancy tech company?
But how do you think about
developing this holistic skill
set?
Being able to explore different
disciplines, different genres.
And I think that's the only
way that you really unlock
passion and true interest.
And that's really
what makes technology
useful and applicable
is somebody that's
taking the new tools
and putting them
in the context of
something that they love.
I'm a firm believer in
the broad education.
And I think if
you listen to some
of the things Mark Cuban's
been saying recently,
some of the things that Jonathan
Rosenberg here at Google
has been saying recently about
the value of liberal arts
in addition to STEM.
You know, we've got to
become technical enough
to be dangerous, to
use the new tools,
to be conversing with data,
to be conversing with these
new things, but not losing
sight of the breadth of exposure
that makes it all
useful to begin with.
And so the liberal arts--
the second deck of the book,
why the liberal arts will
rule the digital world,
it's really kind of about
exactly what you're getting at,
is this breadth of exposure and
how we apply tech meaningfully
to all these different
areas of our lives.
And then, the second
kind of component to that
gets back to the
question of automation,
where if we have these
simple parts of our jobs,
parts of our lives that
are automated away,
which probably will be
over time, what's left
are the complex tasks.
What's left are the tasks where
we trade tasks more frequently.
You're good at one thing.
I'm good at something else.
And there's the guy a Harvard
Graduate School of Education
who talks about the
importance of soft skills.
And he puts it in
the terms of trade,
almost like an economic
argument, where
when there's a lot
of trade, there's
a lot of transaction
costs, or friction.
And the thing that
reduces friction,
that reduces
transaction costs, that
makes teams more effective,
are these social skills.
And so, how do you
train for that?
And I think one way
to train for that
is through real breadth of
exposure, Socratic methodology,
debating in class,
debating at night.
And I think if you're
just on this plane
ticket, one-way plane ticket,
you're not getting that.
So I love the passport,
sort of that metaphor.
AUDIENCE: So you
talked about how
people see the fuzzy and the
techie as separate things.
But truly, to kind
of the way we're
kind of moving towards kind of
seeing how they both interact.
But I guess I'm just graduated
college, or I'm a year out.
But it seems like in these big
companies like Google, or Uber,
or Snapchat, to get
into product or to get
into the techie
side of things, you
do have to have a
techie prerequisite.
So kind of how do you
give advice, I guess,
to someone like me, who's
trying to see, to blend
that fuzzy and techie, to
get to be in the product side
or development of certain
products at a company?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah.
It's a great question.
I think it's true.
At Google, to be on
the product team,
there is a requirement
in some way, shape,
or form of being able
to deal with technology
in a rigorous way.
But there are so many examples.
Like Snapchat, for example.
One of the core people behind
a lot of the product innovation
is a sociologist.
And I talk about him a
little bit in the book.
His name is Nathan Jorgenson.
And he's based in Brooklyn.
He did a PhD in sociology,
and was basically writing
about where he thought
Snap was going,
why he thought it was relevant.
And I think it's a
fascinating case from my seat.
Why did Snapchat take off?
Yet to see if it's
truly successful.
I think it's proven to
be somewhat successful.
At least, it went public,
which is more than we
can say for Uber and others.
But you know, I think given
Instagram, given Google+,
given Facebook, given all these
different platforms that were
out there already,
why did Snap--
why was it able to
break into the market?
And really, I think
the underlying reason
why goes back to Nathan's
insights as a sociologist,
observing sort of
these Gen Zers, who
had grown up in a world
of digital abundance.
In a world where every
photo they had ever taken
was in their Dropbox
or their Google Drive.
Saved infinitely forever.
And he said, how do
you create scarcity
in a world of digital abundance?
You do it by making
things disappear.
And it was this core
understanding, I think,
of the sociological
insight that I think
really gave them an advantage.
And Evan Spiegel read
some of these posts
and immediately hired Nathan,
brought him into Snap.
And now, he's an
instrumental part
of the product organization.
Similarly, I would point to Snap
Spectacles versus Google Glass.
I think that the insight
with Snap Spectacles
is that there is a difference
between clear glasses
and sunglasses, worn indoors
versus worn outdoors.
I think it's a techie-only
approach versus sort
of a fashion-forward approach
of looking at the sociological
insights of how people--
where people want
to wear glasses.
What the inherent
assumptions of trust are.
I think with sunglasses, there's
already this lack of trust
because you can't
see someone's eyes.
If they're recording, if they're
posting, if it's done outdoors,
it's very different
than if you're
sitting in someone's
living room and you
think that you're just having
a private conversation.
And suddenly, it's
being recorded.
So those small
sociological insights,
I think are really
at the core of what
makes a lot of these
products work versus another.
So I think if you
can form a thesis.
If you can sort of
be vocal about having
an opinion of where you see the
market going and sort of owning
that opinion and providing
that perspective to a product
manager, or to a product that
you think is interesting,
I think that's something that
people will find valuable.
And they'll probably bring
you in on a project basis
or bring you in in a
consultative capacity.
And then over time,
that can really
snowball into a lot of
different, interesting
opportunities.
AUDIENCE: I was just
kind of wondering.
I think when you think about
models and machine learning,
I think probably the biggest
risk is, like you said,
the human input part, not
putting enough thought
into what those
inputs are and then
your results can
kind of be skewed.
While I think
there is definitely
a place for people who are
like "fuzzy" if you will,
like is there a
danger in not being
able to look under the hood
and understand what's going on,
what those inputs actually are
in those models when we think
about 10, 15 years from now when
our tasks are being automated,
even for the roles
we're doing today?
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah.
It's a real question
about black box.
I think it's
something that we're
going to be grappling
with for a long time.
You read an econ paper.
And you ask the author
of the econ paper,
why did you assume
this, this, and this?
Those are just words
and people can barely
describe their
assumptions and why they
chose one thing versus another.
And now we're talking
about thousands
of lines of code, things
baked into algorithms,
things pushed out into ones and
zeros, built by composite teams
across the world.
And I think there are these
very real questions of bias,
and who's in the room, and who's
helping make those decisions.
But I do think we need pure
fuzzies in those scenarios
as well.
Because if you look
at predictive policing
as one example, there's so
many things we could probably
do with predictive
analytics around IoT sensors
on police vehicles saying,
OK, where are they going?
Where are they at
certain times of day?
Where is reported crime?
How do we think about deploying
police force in advance
to mitigate crime?
And that seems all
nice and harmless.
But behind the scenes,
you say, well, OK.
Actually, crime data
is reported crime data.
Reported crime
data comes from who
has trust in
community, who feels
acceptable to report crime.
If somebody has a dozen
unpaid parking tickets,
they're probably not calling
the cop for petty theft.
Certain crimes like hate
crimes and sexual assault
are chronically under-reported.
On the flip side,
the arbitrary nature
of if you sit at
one intersection
and you watch how many
people run red lights.
Over time, the
reported crime data
of running red lights in that
intersection will be very high.
You might think that people
are disproportionately
running red lights
at that intersection,
but that just may be a fallacy
in how the data was collected.
So I think these questions
behind the scenes
of if you had a social worker in
the room talking about details
of how crime statistics
are reported,
that's a really important
component to have in the room
if you're about to deploy
predictive policing for Oakland
PD or something.
And so I think you ask a
really important question
that we need to
be thinking about.
And I don't have a good answer.
But really, kind of involving
a plurality of people, diverse
backgrounds.
Fei-Fei Li, who now runs
Google Cloud's Machine Learning
and AI, was at Stanford before.
She's created a
nonprofit called AI4ALL
that's about bringing
women into AI,
bringing different
ethnicities into AI,
different academic
backgrounds into AI.
And I think those
sorts of initiatives
are really important to
get those perspectives
from the ground
floor in how we're
thinking about these things.
Just because we pump
it into ones and zeros
and call it an AI, call
it machine learning,
call it whatever we want,
doesn't make it objective.
It still has all these
implicit assumptions and biases
that are made by humans.
AUDIENCE: So I'm not sure if
you're familiar with Tyler
Cowen, I think it is.
But he runs the blog
"Marginal Revolution."
But anyway, his
vision of the future
is basically that there are
these technical superstars who
become sort of like
the capitalist class.
And they designed the sort of
Ubers for everyone else to use.
But without that skill
set, it's sort of
hard to become a value
producer in society.
And sort of using your
example of the company,
I think it's [? Stitchist ?]
or something,
where the number of
fuzzies just far outweighed
the number of like the
small number of elite data
scientist/techies,
how do you sort
of deal with the question
of these techies--
or is there going to be
big inequality in terms
of earning potential
for people, for fuzzies?
And sort of also, how do
you go about as a company,
like quantifying and valuing
the impact of fuzzies?
Because it seems like something
that's much less tangible.
SCOTT HARTLEY: Yeah.
I mean, the questions
of inequality.
And there's another great
book that I would recommend
that I just picked up.
It's translation
from Dutch, but it's
called "Utopia for Realists."
And it's by a Dutch
author that goes
into the questions of basic
income and some of these ideas
that's really interesting.
I mean on the flip
side of that question,
I think is the democratization
of the toolkits.
And the TensorFlows
of the world.
But The way that you
can kind of-- being
a full-stack integrator,
more and more people
with less and less quote,
"technical expertise"
can actually put these tools
to use in incredible ways.
And from the Google
blog actually,
one example in the book
is about a Japanese farmer
that uses like Arduino
and uses TensorFlow.
And took 3,000 images
of different cucumbers
that he has on his farm and
created a classification engine
to basically auto-sort
all of his cucumbers.
So he created a robotic
system to completely automate
his farming routine.
And so I think we'll equally see
that sort of thing happening.
To the question of
inequality, I think
that's a big-- it's a
big question that we all
need to grapple with.
But the reality is
that if you have
a degree in one
thing versus another
it's a slip of paper
from a university,
it's not a carte blanche
relevance regardless
of what it says.
You know, whether it
says computer science
or anthropology.
What's a really
interesting example
in the book is Zach Sims
when he founded Codecademy,
he dropped out as a
political science major.
He went to MIT
and Harvard to try
to hire all the people to build
Codecademy and none of them
had the requisite coding
skills that he actually needed.
And so he said to all of
them, you need to go upskill.
You need to go to
General Assembly.
You need to go to some
of these platforms
to learn the relevant skills.
And I think it's case in point
for we all have to kind of keep
our education in beta.
We've all got to continually
sort of break the ice
and continue to learn.
Because realistically, if
you're coming out of university
in 2017, who knows what the
job market in 2060 looks like?
Anybody that
speculates has no idea.
So I think the reality is we've
got to keep education in beta,
continually reinvest
in ourselves.
Try to be technical enough
to be dangerous and not
forget some of these other
methodologies as well.
SPEAKER 1: Thank you,
everyone, for coming.
And let's, once again, give
a thank you to Scott Hartley.
[APPLAUSE]
ALBERT CHEN: Thanks
so much, Scott.
SCOTT HARTLEY: Thanks, guys.